силища валим на біляші пункт пропуску
на російсько-фінській кордоні то за право
jeunesse антей з the counter санте
росії
тут був і кілометровий черв'яки swan то he
woke me so we між кінцем кожної до 30
кілометрів на устілці стильний шлях хто
варимо нині вище ставку більше туризм
купуємо нами на фермі кукуємо а саму
фінляндії летять архіву ней а у нас
такого не травня
сир приїжджають туристи сир 10к з метою
були скол відомо то ще плани сам теми
ще більше захотілося санс і одразу ж
ще більше захотів
потім на все може у золота sahbihi
делікатесу через по вершині
економічної ситуації чи то перших
дають при кордоні кафе складаються рану
російські туристи в моїй дружині маємо вас
покараю ще через курс рубля до євро
віддаю перевагу фінляндії та mtp
дорогу владний caviar не хари коко
показують щоденний ви торг гребені
купюри та 100 євро на мойому у team win та
скажіть нам же сигнали далі по
даті не кудись стану кращі росіяни
арени боїться за рота та око до гострої
тут на та безпечний she я захочу буду
обстріл місто пролетить над на ми можемо
його небі веселку боку через лапки рубль
поменшало російських туристів
замшевої фіни відремонтувати частини шиви та
стислий по тайзі кордону
їм тепер ще виграше купава ти в
горілку то бензин близького 5 10
центів за літра в Росії тут домогтися
фільтра євро ризниця о 3 год
крамниця раю хаві через форму будили
російські підручники назвала її шайбою у
нее його на по закрию
коханої дружини травнем доручив йому давати
менше ще біляші торговий центр али
заморозили
до крачок чисел моя стара ти сам тобі
youtube інакше economics
all одягнутий годин ми проживаємо у ми можна
торгово ти уклала ти дуже на
агресію. адже бійся в Україні може
повторити і фінляндією до порожніх
паркувань били супермаркеті фіни ставлю
себе з нордичним спокійний то
прагматизмом чекають доки росія змінити
свою політику і не встигають за ним цією
вивіски російську нову